from cnbc fbi arrests chinese researcher
for visa fraud
after she hid at consulate in san
francisco cnbc reports
a researcher who took refuge in the
chinese consulate in san francisco after
allegedly lying to investigators
about her chinese military service was
arrested and will appear in court on
monday
according to a senior justice department
official according to court documents
unsealed earlier this week in the
eastern district of uh for california
one yuan tang a researcher at the
university of california davis applied
for a non-immigrant j-1 visa october
2019.
the visa was issued in november 2019 and
tang entered the u.s a month later
tang allegedly made fraudulent
statements on her visa application
by concealing that she served in the
chinese military the fbi concluded that
tang was a
uniformed officer of the people's
liberation army air force
after photographs of her were uncovered
on electronic media seized in accordance
with the search warrant
i won't discuss the circumstances of the
arrests of the official who spoke on the
condition of anonymity
adding that the individual did not have
diplomatic immunity
the person said that the details of the
arrest
could be released when the defendant
appears before the eastern district of
california court monday
the issue here is that their true status
wasn't disclosed by visa application
the official said adding that the arrest
was not a tit-for-tat move as tensions
between washington and beijing simmer on
thursday the fbi arrested tang
who had avoided arrest by taking refuge
in the chinese consulate in san
francisco
tang's arrest for alleged visa fraud
follows those of three other chinese
researchers in california and indiana
the arrests were described as a
microcosm of a broader network of
individuals in more than 25 cities
by their very nature consulates are a
base of operations for foreign
governments to the u.s
including their intelligence services
and it's understood that there will be
some activity here by those services
yikes but because of their location
within the united states
and their status of sovereign territory
of a foreign country
they cannot be exploited and the
espionage and influence activities run
out of a consulate
can rise ultimately to a level that
threatens our national security
so this is where it's uh it's getting
spicy man they shut down our
what is this they shut down our
consulate in chengdu
a senior state department official said
the arrests and the closure of the
consulate in houston
are about targeting nefarious chinese
activity inside the u.s
no they straight up called them out for
spying on us oh yeah for sure
right yeah yeah i'm just reading the
quote i know i'm just bringing more
information into the into the fold here
on their decision to close chengdu
you're going to have to ask them
the mfa and how they picked that said
the person who spoke on the condition of
anonymity
referring to the ministry of foreign
affairs the official added the trump
administration was prepared to deal with
second and third order effects in the
wake of the consulate closure
what does that mean i don't know man but
when when i first heard this
it was disconcerting i wonder if the u.s
got permission to enter sovereign
territory to seize a chinese
national yeah maybe well i was i was
actually looking into it and there's uh
their reporting on the chinese side that
those people defected to us
to the us really what that's what i'm
that's what i'm seeing from
from uh some reporters on the chinese
side and um
and even i mean it says here the the
chinese china's foreign ministry
spokesman uh wang wenbin said some of
the us chengdu
consulate personnel where conducting
activity is not in line with their
identities
so they're they're trying to well and
had harmed china's security interests
right right but would not elaborate and
then he goes on to say in an interview
that he
it was like um you know he was speaking
to the public in china and he was
he was basically saying that we made we
made the first move
as americans and we messed up how
we were kicking them out of their
consulate in houston and
that that move is basically
making them look bad and right how dare
how dare we
and the friendship that we had between
american and
china is you know what you're no longer
what's going on with china in the u.s
reminds me of like you've got this one
big brutish dude
yeah and he challenges his little nerdy
guy to a fight or whatever and the nerdy
guy doesn't care about winning by
honorable means so when the big british
dude is like
you think that scrawny guy can take me
i'm the best and the scrawny guy just
hides in the bushes and takes a wrist
rocket and blasts him in the head with a
rock and wins and the guy goes down
yeah so the analogy i'm trying to use
here is so many people keep saying that
oh china is no threat to the u.s there's
no threat to the u.s
do you think that china realizing that
we have this massive technological
advantage
would plan for a conflict based on
physical
force or ground forces they're going to
target infrastructure
manipulate social pressures financial
institutions
it is going to be a subversive
manipulative conflict
i'm fairly certain that's what's been
going on for quite some time
i think well yeah of course mike pompeo
said it yeah they've infiltrated every
level of our of our governments
and institutions and barr said it too he
was talking about the exact same right
all these companies that all of a sudden
you know what's you know what's you know
what sickens me
i'm not going to name the nba players
but you guys probably know who i'm
talking about these these very very high
profile nba players who are like you
know oh we need a movement
and we're going to kneel we're going to
do all these things and then when it
comes to china they're like what's wrong
with china
china is great terrible that's the scary
thing about it it's a shame
it's the money man it's it's greed
greed is disgusting so you have to
wonder why it is that
china suppresses their population in the
way they do with like garbage wages
manipulates their currencies and has
these basic basically massive
sweat shops you know why they're
they're they're man this is horrifying
about collectivism
at this scale these individuals who are
walking off the building at foxconn to
their deaths
that was a big story a long time ago
they put up suicide nets to catch their
bodies
china's the chinese government
sacrifices people in order to get an
edge against
us so they put these people in crammed
garbage apart like
apartments and they pay them trash to
make our phones
that way american companies can't
compete here's what happens phone
company
says how much will it cost us to hire
labor to build these phones
they say well the total cost per phone
will be you know two thousand dollars
yikes
that's way too much well over in china
the total cost will be a hundred dollars
then we can sell them for a thousand and
claim it's cheap that's brilliant
because they suppress their labor and
depress the wages and
and you know put these people in these
horrifying conditions
we we can't compete with that that's why
trump wanted tariffs
that's why he didn't want tpp that's why
bernie sanders originally didn't want
tpp
that's why he wants to bring
manufacturing back here you know exactly
there's so many things in in that
we can we can talk about that for a
while but go go ahead keep going no the
point is
what we're seeing from china is they're
willing to like
lop off their own arm if it means they
win against us in the long run
yeah so if you see this stuff and and i
see a lot of people in the comments
saying things like china is a paper
tiger
they're they're not strong enough they
have a lot of people but they're so weak
they have one aircraft carrier and it's
like
man what did what did sun tzu say about
underestimating your opponent i don't
remember the exact quote but uh
you don't you don't you don't do it
you win the war before you start it
there's a bunch of really brilliant
quotes from sun tzu obviously the art of
war
fairly certain a thousand paper cuts
will still do a lot of damage
right death by a thousand cuts yep so we
can see
listen man over the past several decades
that dylan radigan rant
this country is being extracted through
trade politics finance
that's right yeah we're not buying
american products so our money
isn't staying in america it's going
outside of america to other countries
weakening us it's this simple that's
what trump wants to do
it's really simple if trump didn't come
around
and this is fascinating especially
considering the things i was you know my
position several years ago
if trump didn't do what he did with tpp
and with american manufacturing
i talked about this years ago china
could snap their fingers
and win the war you know why we don't
have medicine
we don't have masks we don't have
manufacturing capabilities
80 of our imports come from china so
here's what happens that's what he means
by saying make america great again
make america great by providing for
ourselves
that's what he wants to do that's what i
want to do if trump should all want that
if trump didn't intervene and the
extraction carried on for another
several years
we would be two more presidents down the
line we'd make literally nothing
the billionaires of the nba in hollywood
would have all their allegiances in
china and all their wealth in china
and then china and they would snap their
fingers
and say we declare war on you america
and we'd be like oh yeah and they'd be
like yeah what you're gonna do you can't
make anything
and then we'd be like oh okay yeah they
would cut off our manufacturing because
they controlled all of it
they were shutting down our ability to
make things
but that executive order that he put in
uh president trump put in
what is it last week now i know i know
it was it was
starting on hong kong but the wordings
that that was in there
was basically saying if you're if you're
connected to the party if you're funded
if
ccp is connected through any means even
if you're bystander
and you you have been helping them in
any way they can freeze your assets
so those millionaires and billionaires
and all that stuff it's like
i'm waiting for it i'm looking i'm
looking for that day that was an
extremely powerful move
yeah it was and now you're you're not
going to see it but i tweeted about this
that i think you've got these
billionaires
that are lobbying for favorable policies
for their interests in foreign companies
not necessarily just in china now
they're going to think twice
when hollywood if if hollywood puts out
a movie
and changes symbols for china trump can
walk up and go
well well well what have we here oh
that's a nice couple hundred million
dollar um
revenue stream we're gonna take it yep
shut it down
thanks hollywood someone's something's
gotta be done about it i don't know to
what degree trump will actually pull
things like that off
but you gotta imagine all of these woke
billionaires that won't
say and say one word against china will
start thinking twice
about about their business operations
damn yeah
you got think about it that that
executive order was broad man
it was like indirectly assisting
somebody
associated with like i know so you could
be a billionaire who
owns a company that you don't pay
attention to and they make shoes and the
shoes are made
in you know shenzhen and then all the uh
shenzhen
yeah and then uh trump goes you're
indirectly funding
you know the owner of that factory which
is a party member i'm going to take your
stuff
i think i i think i clapped when i first
read that clap like
you're in your room and you're like i
was trying i was in my on my desk i was
just reading
reading that part and i was just like
yes
i jokingly clapped for the microphone
but yeah man no i did
so maybe to get conspiratorial i was
talking to uh somebody the other day and
i was like think about everything that's
happened
we may have mentioned this on the show
everything that's happened has been very
fortuitous for us
in the event of a war with china most
we're we've decentralized from our
cities people are fleeing cities
people have bought guns like crazy
non-essential work has been
curtailed and now people are you know
being given resources to stock up on the
things that they choose to get
true it's like it feels like we're gonna
go to war soon
you know oh what is this so oh man
so well i mean we were just kind of
talking about this is
this is not a pl i don't want to say
that this is fortuitous in our favor
because this is terrible for a lot of of
chinese citizens that's going on right
now
but this is the free the three gorgeous
dam and this is so this is from 2017.
so now now i'm gonna i'm gonna click
over this is
this is from june 24th so you can see
the floodgates
are all are open and it is releasing i
mean
this thing is coming this thing is
coming apart why but why are they
dumping the water out
probably because the dam is is is
falling apart
and they need to release the pressure
you know because i thought it was
flooding like overflowing
well that's that well that's what it is
trying to avoid that right right so it's
it's flooding downriver
now this oh i see this is july 9th whoa
so this is really a really bad situation
you know so they they're probably
i guess this is a serious situation for
them so what you're saying
is that the us is using weather control
devices based in alaska known as harp to
control i'm kidding
you know you know what town is going to
take the biggest brunt of this water
which down i bet you can guess wuhan
you're absolutely right no way what is
it so are we already at war is that
what's happening it's crazy man so and
if this dam breaks
it's it's it's kind of like a long
valley all the way to wuhan
so the water won't go anywhere but
straight so it's going to be like a
hundred mile an
hour 100 kilometer hour tsunami coming
from
the mountains down just all the way out
to sea it's terrible it's like it's it's
crazy but like
china is under some serious pressure
right now i got a question for you
what's up if china contacted the united
states right now and said
the dam is about to break and everyone
and everyone
everyone in wuhan will die unless the
united states helps us
right now and deploys and we can stop
this
should the u.s intervene to stop the dam
from breaking absolutely without a doubt
but what about
no doubt we that we we make it part of
the deal
yep absolutely we will absolutely help
you but you
have to abide by this this this this and
this we'll come help you
no doubt i gotta be honest tomorrow
we'll be there but you have to stop
all this stuff you gotta sign these
treaties you got to do this it's like
we want to help you i feel bad for the
chinese citizens that have nothing to do
with the ccp
my i've seen lots of them that they they
hate the ccp my opinion of the ccp is
not high enough to believe they would
accept it
they would they would they would look at
trump you're right and he'd go we'll let
them die
you're right that's true i don't i don't
think they're they were good people i
think these are nasty authoritarians
like i said man
they'll lop off their own arm if it
means getting an advantage against us
and that's that should tell you
everything you need to know about the
ccp they were welding people into their
homes
like look man they literally have
concentration camps they don't they
don't care about their people
they will not give in to our demands no
matter what they're gonna they're
probably sitting there
and the ccp is like yeah let him die
they're probably like well we could
rebuild buffon anyway yeah man
they got a billion 1.4 billion people
they're going to be like
don't care they don't care about the
people who work in parts of it
you know what they were doing in uh
during the olympics when the olympics
came to china
they were taking the water from the
farmers the poor farmers that's right
yeah that th
these this the communist party of china
is and has been
horrifying okay like aren't they now
telling people to take down pictures of
jesus in exchange and to put up mao
yep like man dude
and that guy was nuts scary yeah there's
already been 45 million people that have
been affected by the flood so far
45 million people are already are
already
like look at the difference there it's
insane right this is crazy that the
water was a lot higher but they weren't
releasing anything
now they're trying to like dump as much
as they can yeah so this is
which one's the latest oh wow july 9th
yeah that one
man and i mean i'm finding i haven't
found
this to be true but there is some people
saying that
they're diverting the water towards that
dam
to prevent it from damaging other areas
that are key
components yeah but but that dam is the
power of three nuclear plants
that's a lot of energy apparently not
for the
necessarily for the people that are
downstream but for uh probably a huge
portion surrounding that whole area
so check this out they say on this is
from taiwan news.com.tw
on tuesday the chinese financial news
site kaijeng len yen
released a controversial video that
simulates the devastating flooding that
would occur if the vaunted
three gorges dam collapsed the video
shows the path
the wall of water might take it includes
an estimate of the speed
depth and reach of the flood waters all
the way to wuhang
the video starts out by stating the
height of of the dam is 181 meters above
sea level
its length is 2 355 meters and the
normal reservoir
level is 175 meters with a capacity of
39.3 kilometers
cubed wow that's a lot ominously the
words
once the dam breaks appear as the
animated video shows the damn
disintegrate underwater do
is this the video do they have it i
don't think that's the video it's not
there no
no wow they said as the disc as the
distance from the three gorgeous damned
to the downstream city of
yi chang is only 50 kilometers the video
predicts that within 30 minutes after
the dam breaks
guess hoba dam will be crushed and the
city of yichang destroyed
a flood surge 20 meters in height would
strike each at a speed of 70 kilometers
an hour
and bury it under 10 meters of water
yikes man i know wow oh is this it right
here
maybe i haven't uh i haven't seen oh
here we go
so for those that are listening just
chose the damn break i can't read
chinese so i can't tell you what they're
saying
and then it shows the water wow dude it
just wiped out a city
yep that's the valley i was talking
about so we can see the damn waters are
flooding
down the river and now it just slammed
into another city i think that's a wuhan
yeah and now it's wiping out i'm not
sure if it is or not but it literally
will just wipe out the entire cities and
fill them with water
yep so i wonder what's going on man
why did they build cities there because
they build them near water
well the dam was probably built yeah and
then the water the river
shrank and then people started building
and they're like oh we can we can live
in this area now
that's crazy yeah there was a there was
a a
video i did on this place in i think
it's called saint thomas
in nevada i could be wrong but it was uh
there was an old town and then when they
built the dam it was the inverse when
they built the hoover dam water started
to fill up on the other side i guess
and it flooded the whole area and so
they just abandoned it
and now when the drought hit in the past
few years you could actually walk
out and go to where the old foundations
of the city used to be
i remember that video yeah man they're
they're facing some serious
some serious trouble and i have to
wonder if a lot of what they're doing
might be acts of desperation because of
it
yeah there's a lot of there's a lot of
desperation or maybe there's secretly a
war going on we don't know about
maybe the whole goal of modern
information age warfare is to prevent
people from learning what's really
happening
i mean that sounds pretty accurate uh
yeah but like i you know
i say things like how would you do it
how would you be able to pull it off
and i think the reality is there's
probably things we don't know about in
their technology they've probably got
crazy tech we haven't yet
you know seen publicly you think that's
what this uh
this new all this talk about you know
not from this earth crafts that the
aliens found
you know it's like i mean like who knows
it's like just because we didn't
make it doesn't mean like another
country could have made it or right
right
i don't know for those that were
following this uh a pentagon consultant
said that they have vehicles that were
made off-world
not of this earth or something yeah i'm
going to have to see that before i
believe it
yeah i think i actually have a story for
the national review pentagon consultant
briefed senators on discovery of
off-world vehicles
not made on this earth the reality is he
just
said he concluded right they're
off-world vehicles
so let's i want to keep the focus on
what's going on with china to be honest
because the ufo stuff is the same
same area yeah definitely but here's
here's the thing
in all likelihood whatever they
discovered i don't understand i mean
astrophysicist so i defer to him but why
wouldn't the first assumption be what
has china invented
you know in a long long time ago the bow
and arrow was like
the the pinnacle of weapons technology
it changed the world
and when properly used on horseback you
were
undefeatable amazing you'd run in and
like doom doom just arrow arrow arrow
you won the war
like that and we've continually advanced
our weaponry
the most powerful weapons that we know
of nuclear weapons
and more and more powerful and bigger
and bigger but is that really the most
effective way to win a war it's not
information manipulation is that's true
in which case i'm not
it's not surprising to see ddos attacks
major hacks by the chinese government
and cyber warfare be the
be the you know the true warfare that we
see today or mental
manipulation yeah you know take it a
step further like when you see
weird companies investing in news
organizations in the united states from
foreign governments
and only some of them get called out you
know russia today
is it's complete fake news but al
jazeera that's good yeah fine
same thing and and even i mean to be
fair even the the
cbc and the bbc foreign companies
broadcasting in the us
do not have our best interests they're
going to say things the way they want
them to be portrayed
for their interests not ours
i don't know what you do about it but
i'll tell you what we have jinwa in the
united states
and if you go to uh times square
i don't know if they still do but for a
long time like one of the tallest
advertisements was a genuine
advertisement that's the chinese state
news agency
literally chinese propaganda it's like
you you don't
run a company in china unless it's the
government like they control it
you know thanks for checking out this
clip from the tim cast irl podcast we do
the show
live monday through friday at 8 pm if
you want to catch the full show
tune in to this channel subscribe hit
the like button or
check us out on itunes and spotify and
we will soon have this podcast up for
free
on all podcast platforms thanks for
hanging out and we'll see you all in the
next episode
you